we're trying to make it work really
well it's the people are all very
motivated and enthusiastic just like us
a lot of streets just like that
personally it's just good people
see
here
4 the
aim here is to build bridges between
people in communal accommodation
or decentralized living
from the once to real people of
this one another
we live here seriously if you
minimize prejudices reservations just
work through the bureaucratic German without the volunteers know
where there is help and money
so there is relief
we have repeatedly put ourselves
in the position to this day we  are in
any arab town
get an empty apartment there